hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is
mary carr mary carr lit on twitter
she's the author of three award-winning
best-selling memoirs
the liars club cherry and lit she's also
the author of the art of memoir one of
my absolute favorites
which lays bare her own process as she
breaks down the craft of memoir and
tropic of squalor
her latest volume of poetry a guggenheim
fellow in poetry carr has won push cart
prizes for both verse and essays
other grants include the whiting award
penn martha all brand award
and a radcliffe bunting institute
fellowship car is also a peck professor
of literature at syracuse
university you can find her online at
marycar.com
on twitter at marycarlitt
this episode is brought to you by
shipstation the holiday season is fast
approaching and we know that people will
be buying more stuff online than ever
before
all of these trends to e-commerce have
been accelerated due to covid and much
more
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of
record-breaking online shopping season
be ready with shipstation
shipstation.com is the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks you're managing
orders printing out discounted shipping
labels and getting your products
out fast happier holidays for you and
your customers shipstation takes the
hassle out of holiday shipping
no matter where you're selling on amazon
etsy your website via shopify or other
platforms
shipstation brings all of your orders
into one simple
interface and shipstation works with all
of the major carriers usps
fedex ups even international you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution every time
and you can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved for
large fortune 500 companies it's no
wonder that shipstation is the number
one choice of online sellers and right
now
my listeners that's you guys can try
shipstation free
for 60 days when you use offer code tim
just go to the homepage shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in
tim tim that's it go to shipstation.com
then enter offer code tim
shipstation.com
make ship happen
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all that all good
things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helix
sleep.com tim take their two-minute
sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free
they'll even pick it up from you if you
don't love it and now my dear listeners
helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free is an
upgraded deal so that's up to 200 off
and two free pillows at helix sleep dot
com
slash tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep dot com slash tim for up to two
hundred dollars off
so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hand starts
shaking
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
[Music]
mary welcome to the show hey tim thanks
for having me
and i appreciate you putting me at ease
when i mentioned that i have
copious notes in front of me and that's
usually an indication that i
am nervous and not you
you do this all the time you're gonna
kill it you're it's gonna go great
i'm convinced and thank you and you
reassured me by saying
i make really good waffles that's what
i'm like
i'm like a nona you gotta think of me as
a nona out here
let's rewind the clock as a first step
in podcastville
and maybe we can talk about known as in
the family lineage
of sorts and i want to talk about or
have you speak to
a guy redoing your mother's kitchen and
holding up a tile
could you perhaps elaborate on that
please oh yeah yeah
right after my first memorial was
published we were having my mother's
kitchen retired
my sister and i were there and that yeah
and the tile dude a prize off a towel
and he holds it up
and it has a little round toilet and and
he looks at my
little fluffy-haired gray-haired mother
and says
miss card this looks like a bullet hole
and my sister says mom
isn't that where you shot at daddy and
she says
no that's where i shot at larry over
there is where i shot at your daddy so
people asked me why i wanted to be a
memoirist i'm like why would you make
stuff
up when that's who your mother is
so for those who have no context i'd
like to provide a bit more context
where was this kitchen or where is this
kitchen for that this kitchen is in
southeast texas it's a town that i
write about to protect the mayor and the
school principal and the
people who didn't sign off on what i
said about them
i call it leechfield but it's really
it's uh east of port arthur texas a
small town in
east texas i call it the ringworm belt
which which i've also heard you describe
as a swampy town
so moisture humidity ringworm as a
former wrestler i can say those things
combine to produce exactly
yes no that's it an industrial like a
lot of oil refineries all around so not
vienna you know not paris in the 20s i
guess is the way i would
put it now i'm going to hop around like
memento the movie
if i must and i must because that is my
way and
you've written extensively about your
childhood you had in many respects an
extremely
difficult painful childhood and
will probably unwind some of that
now you've written extensively about it
and you've also
mentioned about writing memoirs
and if this is a misquote please call me
out quote i've said it's hard
here's how hard everybody i know who
wades deep enough into memories waters
drowns a little
and certainly in your book you paint a
high resolution picture of just how
painful that can be
and certainly an element might be
catharsis but it is
painful and i would love for you to
speak to
the catalyst for beginning to
publish this type of work write and then
publish this type of word
the publishing is nothing compared to
the writing i think publishing for me
was great because they gave me money and
i didn't have any so
that was that was good but yeah i
i think i had a flamethrower on my ass
can i say ass on your show
you can say ass not only are our
three-letter words
allowed for letter are allowed as well
oh there we go you know i was a weird
little kid
and i was just my mother was capital and
nervous and
married seven times and twice to my
daddy and
and uh both my parents drank hard it was
texas
everybody was armed and we were a loud
combative
house so i loved my parents i mean
that's what i should say
it's i don't think anybody who's read
anything i've written about them
would challenge that but it was not
a safe childhood and yes it had its fair
share of
blows i mean i i always you know look i
was born in the richest country in the
world
i'm my skin color is something the whole
country privileges
i'm you know i'm a college professor
i've you know i
grew up skinny and my teeth came in
relatively straight and i have a lot of
advantages so
whatever i went through a lot of people
and people i grew up with and loved had
it way worse
and didn't make it so i think i was
haunted i was a haunted little girl i
tried to kill myself when i was
a kid when i was still in grade school i
took a bunch of aspirin
it said pain relief and i thought okay
this is what i want
and so i didn't have a choice i was
in some ways not having a choice was a
lucky thing because i
went into therapy very early i managed
to get after
leaving school without a diploma i
managed to
weasel my way into college and had a
really kind professor and his wife kind
of took me under their wing and urged me
to go
into therapy when i was 19 and
so i was sitting in rooms talking to
you know codependent social workers
starting when i was a kid
and all of that helped but i guess i've
been really blessed with a lot of
outside help i'm a big
big fan of the mental health
professional and the
librarians and english teachers and
those kind souls you meet along the way
so you have consoles that you meet in
person you mentioned a few and i want to
talk more about weasling into college in
a few minutes but
i've read a lot about your reading
if that makes sense yeah i read a lot
yeah
some might envision in their minds eye
the childhood you described as
a family of illiterates nobody picked up
anything other than
people magazine but that was not the
case no the huge advantage
yeah describe that a little bit and also
if i could tag on
an additional piece of that question
i've heard you describe
finding and reading poetry as
eucharistic
and i would love for you to just speak
to that
as well yeah i started reading poetry
when i was a little girl
and i you know reading is socially
sanctioned disassociation
you're if you you know if you can't they
won't let you drink or
you know geez heroin when you're a
little kid but but you can disappear
down a valley of
winnie the pooh or charlotte's web or
and
in some ways the poets i read i think a
lot of i think poetry really captured me
early and my my mother had
who was a painter had gone to art school
in new york and was
enormously well read there were books
all over my house in a place
for the nearest bookstore the bookstores
in my town sold
you know bibles as big as station wagons
and
and uh you know little little dashboard
icons but that
there weren't a lot of there wasn't a
lot of literature to buy
but uh i found a home in the little
library was a three block walk from my
house and
i could disappear down the snowy valley
of a book and i was somewhere else
and so poetry saved my life i mean my
best friends were poets i think the way
people worship saints and you know
have crosses blessed i felt that way i
and if you think about the idea of the
eucharist we weren't catholic we were
atheists my father was a union organizer
and said you know
church is a trick on poor people to get
their money away from
them and my mother was a kind of marxist
lady who was very smart and you know
just a loose
a little bit of a loose cannon so we
were not churchy in the bible belt
and um yeah you take someone when you
read a poem you know you
you put it in the meat of your body i
mean you're a body person
i'm a body person i feel like you take
somebody else's suffering
into you and it changes you
it transforms you i had this idea of
being a poet starting when i was five or
six years old
that i wanted to be a poet it was the
strangest thing because
there were no poets around no one had
ever no one i knew had ever met a poet
what was the feeling that elicited that
desire
was it just these tangible
brilliance in some type of word play was
it
a kinesthetic reaction
to the aesthetics of certain poets
what was it that wow produce that desire
you said it better than my good tim you
win
i mean it's not a joke that i use the
riverside shakespeare as a booster seat
that's literally what happened i sat
when i had to reach the table i sat on
this giant
edition of shakespeare my mother had
that was very water stained
and i was a you know a book
that i read very early and i started
memorizing
not shakespeare poems but the speeches
from hamlet and
romeo and juliet and macbeth and
and richard iii and i would memorize
these speeches and say them to my
you know hungover mother and she liked
it
you know it was something she encour i
got her attention that way she was a
very
to say she was not nurturing
i mean lady macbeth is probably
uh not nurturing the way my mother was
not nurturing she
she was her disinterest in being a
mother was profound let's just put it
that way
she once said to me when i was early
early on when i was getting sober i
she was supposed to watch my little boy
was then a toddler when i went to an aaa
meeting and
i came back one day and she was like she
said i can't keep him he's just too
i mean i was gone for an hour and a half
she said i just don't do kids
and i was so mad i said mother you had
four children what do you mean you don't
do
kids you don't cook you don't clean you
haven't had a job in 40 years
what exactly do you bring to the party
and she thought for a minute she said
i'm a lot of fun to be with
you i forgot to do anything for any
other
living human being but i am fun to be
with which was not untrue
so i guess i had an aesthetic sense
uh she played music she played opera she
played blues
janice joplin grew up in my hometown or
whether i grew up in her hometown since
she was older her
brother would be in my high school
carpool so there was a lot of music i
listened to
and i think poetry was part of that the
form the shape i
you know what it felt like tim i felt
less lonely i was a lonely person and i
would read these poems and i felt like
someone understands me someone
knows what it feels like to occupy this
body and i remember trying to tell
other little kids in my neighborhood
about it about poems that i liked
there's a e cummings poem i once tried
to tell some girls about in my school
you know it's just spring in the world
is mud luscious and the little lame
balloon man
whistles far and we and eddie and bill
came come running
and it's spring and the world is a petal
wonderful and the goat-footed balloon
man whistles firmly something like that
i can't even remember it but
it's so long ago that's pretty good for
not remembering i can remember
little bits of it but i remember these
girls in my school just going
what are you talking about like that
doesn't make any sense and i'm like
what about it doesn't make any sense you
know it's about it's being spring and
it's
and she's like well what is the mud
luscious like that's not even a word
i mean no it's like muddy and luscious
and delicious
and it's like how is mud delicious you
know it's like
like no like y'all aren't getting it and
i thought they were messing with me it
seemed so
obvious to me how great this was
so i learned to shut up about it very
early
you know by like third fourth grade i
learned just don't you like this stuff
nobody else
your mother likes it your sister likes
it your daddy likes it nobody else is
gonna like it you shut up
one expression that i think was in the
art of memoir
i've read it in other interviews and
again i'm probably gonna paraphrase here
but that
poetry should disturb the comfortable
and comfort the disturbed yes i wish
that were my
line isn't that a great line it's so
good where is that from
or do you recall where you learned it
yes i know i know
vaguely where it's from but i can't
remember the guy's name you can google
it
it's um we'll find it early 20th century
maybe 1920s to 1950
journalist guy so i'm sorry i didn't i
don't
cite it i wish i could take credit for
it but yeah
all art should disturb the comfortable
and comfort this is disturbed and
all therapy should and most foods
you know it's not a bad goal to shoot
for at the beginning of a day
how did you weasel into college if you
could
flash flashback because i would
imagine that there's some listeners like
me who are just
in their minds eyes seeing this little
girl
sitting on shakespeare and out of focus
behind her head in the same kitchen
are bullet holes in the tile
imagining the experience and the
experiences although
truly you endured some horrific horrific
things
but wondering how does someone in that
position
get into college especially when they're
missing
at least based on some of my homework
for instance 87 days of school in the
sixth grade things like this
how on earth did someone get into
college was it your
wielding of words and an essay that just
unlocked it was it
i won an essay contest when i was in
high school i remember
i think it was from the national council
of teachers of english
and i had some professors actually my
my mother had gone back to graduate
school
and got me a recommendation from this
teacher of chinese history who felt me
up
sexually assaulted me in his office and
then wrote me a recommendation
and so maybe that helped actually what i
think helped when i look back on it was
i had
i opposed the vietnam war and i wore
black armbands on moratorium day
and and that's the kind of thing that
where i grew up
you know i remember my coach of the
football coach
pinning me up physically like pinning me
up against the lockers by the front of
my shirt
and holding me against the lockers and
threatening me essentially
to take my black armband off so i did
things like i didn't stand up for the
american flag i mean i don't know i
thought i was calling kaepernick or
something it didn't win me any friends
let me just say that but i later found
out when i got to my school and i had a
i had to have a lot of jobs to go there
because it was a private school it was
mcalester college it wasn't it was a
it's a very good school and i later
found out that the assistant principal
of my high school who had thrown me out
a lot
for things like my skirt was too short
one time he threw him out for not having
a bra on and i said
what makes you think i don't have a bra
and then he called in the gym teacher to
look under my shirt and confirm in fact
i didn't have a bra so i was just i was
a pain in his ass
and i later found out that he called
mcallister and told these people
in the admissions office that i was a
bad citizen
that i wouldn't stand up for the pledge
of allegiance and stuff well they hear
this old
redneck assistant principal and they
hear about this little girl who's doing
this and they think she sounds great
she's perfect perfect
so i actually think my misbehavior that
got me in so much trouble and made him
hate me so much
i once had an algebra teacher revealed
to me he really is after you like you're
not
paranoid like he's he's real he wants
you out of here
and so i actually think i don't know how
i got in
i don't know how i got it was clearly a
mistake i made a d
in art you know my senior year and my
mother was a painter
so i mean all i had to do was slap art
on
something and i would get have gotten
you know a b
and i couldn't i couldn't handle the
pressure it was too hard
so i don't know how i got to college but
once i got to college i've got to say i
really
well everybody else was complaining
about their parents and the
you know i don't know that you that you
couldn't
weren't supposed to smoke pot in your or
whatever they were mad about
i was like this is great this is
all these people read books and they'll
talk to you about them and
i made straight a's and i got a
scholarship and it was just shocking
uh to me that i might succeed at
something you know
what about the environment aside from
people who read books and are willing to
listen
if it was the environment maybe there
are other variables
led to the straight a's was it being
outside of your home environment
like what was the recipe that
contributed
to that sort of conversion of sorts from
d for defiant
to straight a maybe you were still
defiant but you got straight a's
i wasn't defiant i was i wanted to
please people i mean
i think i had a lot of jobs like i had a
job
i had one of those hair net wearing jobs
at the food service ready to go in at
like four in the morning and like
cook scrambled eggs and wash dishes and
stuff and so i think in some ways i had
to organize my time but
i had been living with a bunch of drug
dealers before i went to college out in
southern california we moved out there
initially we lived in cars and stuff and
then we got some a couple of us were
slinging dope
mostly pod and psychedelics although one
guy had robbed a drug store and
it was just it was i hitch was
hitchhiking one day
from laguna beach to san clemente where
my friends were surfing and i got picked
up by a guy who
really scared me i thought he was gonna
rape me
and had to jump out on the side of the
road and it's interesting because there
were six of us who lived in that house
when i left home and of the six four
went to jail and two of those were dead
before they were 20.
and only me and one other guy might
who's still my best friend dooney
wound up getting sober and we both kind
of made it quote unquote him in
construction in southern california and
me doing whatever it is that i'm
supposed to be doing so i was scared i
was scared
by how dark things
that i brought to darkness with me you
know you get to southern california from
where i grew up and you're like
where has all this been you know
everybody's orthodontic and
you know you know the people's teeth are
great and nobody's missing any
digits or anything they nobody's you
know
everybody looks so amazing and
everything's so beautiful and you're
like god i've never seen anything like
this
a golly and so you would think
everything would have been great but
you know as you know when you have a lot
of trauma growing up you bring the
darkness with you so
i had this idea after that i was
hitchhiking and i got scared i had to
jump out of this i tried to went to jump
out of this guy's car
it was a volkswagen and that had no back
seat and had a bunch of garbage in it
and i pulled up on the
handle of the door and it just went
floppy round and round and round
like it was locked and i couldn't get
out
and so the window was open stuck open
wouldn't go up we can go down and i
stuck my arm out the side of the
window and opened it from the outside
and and jumped out and went down this
like embankment on the side of the road
and i was i was
really scared i was you know how those
moments of trauma are i was scared like
i had been when i was a little kid and
there were
bullets flying around my house and i
thought i know you know i'll go to
college in minnesota
and i mean it's just that was the other
thing everybody in minnesota is so damn
nice have you ever been there
i have i have just spent time there i
couldn't well i used to make a joke
about
about my call an unkind joke i'd say if
you're not a virgin when you get here
you will be when you leave
it was just everybody was so damn
nice oh my god i'd never seen such nice
people
in my life and still i got there and i
did extremely well for two years and i
won all these prizes
and then i dropped out i couldn't handle
the prosperity you know i couldn't
handle the success
so i was a long way it took me a while
to
finally start getting sober i guess i
guess that was a lot of my problem
which we will definitely talk about i
want to dig into that and i also
am going to ask you just to plant a seed
about
how those mentors initially convinced
you
to go to therapy but first i want to
bounce around
chronologically yes because from these
origins
i've in the process of doing my homework
read about your graduate seminar
at syracuse described as hyper selective
and
certainly a writer and poet of great
note at this point right lots of people
know who you are lots of people love
your work lots of people love
you describing the craft and process
goes into your work
how do you select the students who make
it into your graduate seminar or how did
you
i mean i do it it's i wish i wish they
would just
give me a wand and i get to pick all my
people but interestingly
i've been teaching their gosh 30 years
something like that i only teach in the
fall and i go and
i commute and from new york city so
we do it based on the work we do it
solely based on the writing and
you know some years george saunders my
colleague
george saunders had gotten so fit has
gotten so famous
that you know he attracts a lot of
people and have a lot of people who
teach their arthur flowers juno diaz is
taught there
we just we have gotten up to you know
1200 applications
for 12 positions
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis
you would have missed out on 50 percent
five zero percent of your returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested in a long-term
automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and
lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up and then wealthfront
will build you a globally diversified
portfolio of etfs based on your
risk appetite and manage it for you at
an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life
that's wealthfront.comtim wealthfront
will automate your investments for the
long term
and you can get started today at
wealthfront.com
tim
you end up with these these 12
gems of assorted colors and kinds
yes what is day one class one what does
that look like
oh you're thinking i meant when i teach
my memoir class yeah well i used to do
i used to do this thing yeah that's so
funny
i used to do this thing where i would
stage a fight
in my class with someone who was
opposite from me
and uh so let's say you know like my
colleague george saunders who is
just the sweetest guy i can't even tell
you i
i was in the car with him once and there
was a bug on his shirt and i was like
george there's a big beetle on your
shirt and he'd be like
well he has to be somewhere
you know i'd be like kill it and he's
like this
this tibetan buddhist with this amazing
practice you know just the sweetest guy
so george comes in and starts arguing
with me that my classroom
is in fact his classroom and this is in
front of all the students in front of
all the students and it's for them it's
the first day of school and it's like
having their parents fight
and i script it so that i say
only nice conciliatory things i back up
he walks forward he's bigger than i am
and then
it ends with with him like throwing the
papers up and
you know telling me to go [ __ ] myself or
something and are telling me to
go hang maybe i don't know if you can
say the f word can you say the f word
f word is not not only allowed but
endorsed
i grew up on long island you're in good
company i feel so much better
just tell me to go [ __ ] myself and and
then we ask the students to write so
let's say there are
17 18 students in this class 20
somewhere between 15 and 22. and they're
all
smart and they're all young they were
all
incredibly juiced on adrenaline and
cortisol
because they were scared and it's a
public scene
and they don't really know each other
that well and they don't know us that
well so they're all
extremely alert they're hyper vigilant
and we ask them to write down what
happens and everybody writes something
just a little different
interestingly people will describe me
in very aggressive terms like
even though i'm the one backing up and
i'm saying well i can clear out during
the break george but like
i don't understand why you're so upset
and he'll say you don't
understand why i'm so i mean he walks
forwards and i'm backing up and my head
is down and i'm doing every conciliatory
gesture i can think of and people will
say
you know she stood her ground like a
bulldog or
she had military strength facing off
against him
and one year i did it with my student
assistant who was a
an undergraduate just a beautiful young
track star betsy and
you know betsy just threw her papers up
in the air and
was screeching at me well you know she's
this kid and here i am this professor
with you know fancy clothes in a
position of power
so people would in that class of
undergraduates assume that i had done
horrible things to betsy that had in one
class
there was a young woman one of the ruses
i set up is that i leave my cell phone
on so i can start to argue with george
before he comes in and then asks the
students you know how often did he call
how long between each call and ask them
to guess things or remember things about
time
and some people's that he calls three
times some people will say he called
once
some people four times so
all those details are very influenced
by who they are the young woman with
sickle cell anemia will
have this enormous compassion for me
because i'll say i have to leave my
phone on
i'm waiting for medical results and
she'll assume
i'm waiting to hear if i have some awful
ailment
and she sees george as a complete beast
and me as this woman perhaps ill who
dragged herself to class
while everybody else in the class thinks
what a diva she's answering her phone in
the middle of class she can't wait an
hour to get medical results i mean come
on
so there are always people in
in class who have identic you have those
perfect memories i remember one kid
often they're musicians
this kid was a jazz saxophone player who
was very famous in brooklyn for giving
these amazing
house parties i think he made a living
giving house parties for like
i don't know years so this kid had this
amazing memory he got
we had a script and he remembered the
script exactly he remembered what george
had on he remembered where we stood he
remembered that i backed up
every step and then when he wrote it he
wrote it exactly as it happened he
didn't miss anything
and he said george was the aggressor but
i wonder what she'd done to make him act
that way
i guess the purpose of the exercise is
for you to realize that you remember
through a filter of who you
are memory is not a computer it's not a
perfect storage system
obviously we even these fine minds of
these young people
very alert and paying attention in their
first class and wanting to get
everything right and do well
misremember and what's more what i want
them to think about is how
they are not just perceiving things but
beaming
the world the landscape into being with
whoever they are inside
it's important as a writer of anything
to realize what kind of filters you're
strapping on
that prevents you from seeing what's
going on i would imagine
that is an opening exercise
that a lot of your students remember
speaking of memory for a very very long
time what other
exercises or aspects of your teaching it
could be in
in any setting do many of your students
remember or have stick out for them
would you imagine
i think a lot of practice things a lot
of
i think it's important as a writer or as
in anything
to develop you know habits i mean you
talk about this and
for our body for our work week you've
developed a lot of practices
in your life to shape your life so that
you were
kind of operating you know to constantly
be growing and developing and so
things like keeping a commonplace book
just keeping a notebook where you write
down
beautiful pieces of language what is a
commonplace book
that is where you capture the sort of
beautiful turns of phrase that you
encounter yeah things you read so you
might copy poems
you might copy over here
is something you ever heard on the
street there was a guy
standing on my street this is like a
couple of years ago when i first moved
into this apartment
screaming murder or suicide
at the top of his lungs and everybody
was walking around the street
walking around him and it was early in
the morning
and i walked up to him and he said
excuse me sir
he was screaming murder suicide murder
or suicide and i went up to him and said
sir isn't there like a third
alternative like isn't there a door
number three
and
that little encounter i wrote down but
but things i over
hold on hold on that's too much of a
cliffhanger so what happened when you
said that
well you know what was beautiful uh i
went into
i was going in to get a pastry for a
friend of mine who was visiting from
london
i got him one i thought i'd bring him a
pastry when i came out but when i
walked into the bakery he was looking at
the sky
you know with a curious look you know he
was thinking
like isn't there a door isn't there a
door isn't there another
gosh there might just be a door number
three
but mostly what i write down are pieces
of language or things
poems that i read paragraphs
anything so that you're just constantly
copying in longhand you can't type it
you're
you're constantly copying things that
are beautiful you're constantly
guzzling beauty you're guzzling the
beautiful language so that you're kind
of steeped in it
you know like a fruitcake and good
and good brandy is the value of
the commonplace book and using it this
way in the writing down or do you
have some approach to
review or
using that later you know i i
occasionally i mean the great thing
about them
is that if you get on an airplane or
you're going along you sort of
know what you're reading but i've also
been doing this
a poet named stanley kunitz who was a
poet laureate in like 1978 or something
told me to do this so i've been doing
this since 1978.
also every time i give a lecture i put
the quotes i use in the lecture on
on index cards and so i have like you
know i've been teaching for 40 years i
mean i
i have 40 years of index cards with
quotes on them
it's oddly satisfying i don't know what
it is it's but it's just like
it's like a sit-up you do it's like a
push-up you do
it's uh something you don't really i
often don't look back and i think it's
in the writing down i think it's in the
practice
and kind of it's like an altar you're
making an
altar for yourself every day
you know i wanted to might as well use
this as a segue
alter could you speak to the importance
or utility of prayer in your life
yeah i mean i'm a prayer i was an
atheist my whole life
and i got sober in 1989
and believe me i drank my share i did my
part
i remember some guy i went to high
school with telling me
i was when my mother was still alive i
was home and he says you don't even
you don't even drink anymore you don't
even smoke pot
i was like no jack-o'-lantern i i don't
i don't do that stuff anymore it's like
why i was like well
it just didn't agree with me you know it
made me do things that
i didn't want to do and he says i just
think you're a quitter
i just think you're a quitter i just
think you gave up
i mean what is smoking pot gonna do
you're never gonna like
rob anybody's television or anything he
said well that's true
that's true enough jack-o'-lantern but
you have had this job pumping gas since
the 11th grade
please tell me this guy's name was
actually jack lantern
his name was jack we called him
jack-o'-lantern because of a sad tooth
and because we were not ones to stand on
ceremony and he said uh
i said you have had this job since the
11th grade and you're 50 years old and
you have an
ambition deficit disorder
buy my yardstick so no but he would say
jacqueline
he'd say don't call me that no more i'm
like what do you want me to call you
like that's your name dude that's been
your name since you were 15. that's your
name
what does prayer look like for you what
does praying i think it started off
i think poems were my first prayers the
ones that i read like i said i
felt less lonely so i started praying
not out of any virtue not i didn't
believe in god
i had no i had no religious training
whatsoever
when i was a little girl you know people
would say
would talk about santa claus or the
easter bunny i thought they were kidding
i thought they don't really believe this
horse [ __ ] i mean
you know i knew i figured out pretty
early on you know by the time i was like
six or seven people were serious that
they prayed when people weren't looking
at them
i couldn't believe it it was shocking to
me and daddy would say well you know
folks ignorant
you know what you're gonna do so i had
not a religious bone in my body but i
did notice when i tried to stop drinking
that i couldn't like like that
i tried to stop drinking for two or
three years
and i tried by myself and i tried
drinking only beer and i tried drinking
only alone i tried drinking with other
people i tried drinking only wine i
tried drinking with food i tried
drinking
you know weekends not i mean i just
somehow i had crossed some line
where i just couldn't i couldn't stop
drinking
and i went to get help and i went to
satin church basements and i
hated everybody i saw who was sober i
just hated them they just seemed like
you know the guys selling incense at the
airport i just didn't like them
um they just didn't look fun and i just
they were so nice too it was like
getting to minnesota they're hi
you know welcome i'd be like oh god i
hate these people
and finally the last time i drank the
last night i drank i had gotten i gotten
together for like
it was the longest amount of time sober
i'd had since i was 15 and i got
together 90 days sober by going and
you know sitting in church basements and
talking to people who were sober
and i got a 90-day chip and then i had
to give this talk
i had to give a poetry reading at
harvard to interrupt
just since i i don't have much
familiarity when you say a 90-day chip
is that some like literal token that you
were given because it looks like a poker
chip
and so like you get one the first day
you go and you get one at 30 days and
and 60 days in 90 days so this was for
me
an epic accomplishment i mean there was
no time that i ever
ran the hundred yard dash in that was as
important to me
as that 90-day chip and i was
happy that i was sober i felt better i
was sleeping better my kid was better
everything was better
and i had to give this poetry reading at
harvard college and i
didn't i was nervous i'd never given a
reading without drinking
the reading went okay i was teaching at
a bunch of places
including one class there and i went out
with some of my
students and the next thing i know it's
three o'clock in the morning and i'm
my car spinning out on store drive and
in boston and and i'm going towards this
concrete
and i somehow didn't crash the car and i
somehow got home
and and so at that point
everybody had been saying you know got
to get on your knees and pray and there
was this great uh heroin addict
uh recovering heroin addict janice at
this halfway house where i did
volunteer work i drove people to
meetings
basically and i would pick people up and
drive them to meetings
a lot of disabled people and gina said
just get on your knees and i'm like
janice you know i don't
i what kind of god wants me to grovel
and go
oh god you're so great and she said you
don't do it for god you [ __ ]
in that boston accent you don't do it to
god you [ __ ]
i'm like well who am i doing it for it's
like you're doing it for yourself
just get on your knees just say help me
stay sober
in the morning get on your knees and i
say thank you for helping me stay sober
and so i'd be like okay so i get on my
knees help me stay sober
and tonight i'd say thank you for
helping me stay sober well some weird
things started to happen
i mean sometimes i would literally shoot
the finger at the light fixture because
i just thought
i hate this you know what's terrifying
about praying
is the loneliness of it i always tell
people
young women i i sponsor you show more
faith praying when you have never prayed
before then any nun
to sit in that silence with all your
fears and all your self-doubt
is so scary and hard if you have a big
loud head
like i do and like i have a big inner
life and
and in my mind never has anything good
to say it
thinks it can kill me and go on living
without me
something started to happen i would have
these moments of quiet
and the only way i can describe it is it
was south of my neck
it was like in the middle of my chest if
if i was living my life with my head
like yammering at me like a chihuahua
all day
do this don't that stupid [ __ ] put that
down pick that up go over there
i mean it was just eat this don't eat
that
call him i hate him you know like just
these
moments like in the middle of my chest
would be like this
broad expanse of quiet
and i remember one particular day our
little shitty car broke down my kid was
a toddler and he was
i had to pee we were on the road i
didn't break down i had a flat
and didn't have a spare a working spare
it was rush hour we were on memorial
driver trying to get home
and i just in that moment what i
normally would have done you know i
would have been there
you know like throwing the jack around
and trying to get the car jacked up and
in a state of indignant fury that
i didn't believe in god but i believed
that there was fate
that had doomed me to misery and that
the guy with the jaguar would always get
my parking place right before i pulled
in and
and i believed i had a head that had
memorized the bad news and and
spewed it out all day and i remember
that day it was the sun was setting
i just got out on the side of the road i
got dev out of his car seat
and the sun was going down and he was
looking at me afraid
that i was going to be like angry and i
just sat there and he said
he was hungry and i didn't have anything
to eat in the car and i'm sitting there
and i said let's just look at the sunset
a minute and then we'll
we'll go we'll walk and we'll get some
help and we were just sitting there
looking at the sunset and this truck
pulls up
with these goomba guys from from this
12-step meeting and
they have ginger ale they have a jack
they have
a way to tow my car they give deb
potato chips and it was just like
you know all i have to do is just find
some space in my body
and just wait for a minute and
so i started to notice
things happening when i wasn't
bent over the day like a dog over like a
bone that was about to be stolen
you know like that when i could just
i could just like sit there for a moment
and so i began to get a space
in my body and i began to get
i began to hear not the voice of god i
would call it
i would have some leanings like i would
be thinking
i should have just killed myself like
literally this is what i'd be
i should have killed myself my husband
would marry some
nice girl who wore berets and my son
would have this great mother and
and his life would be better if i
weren't there
and i would hear this voice in my head
that was like
you need a sandwich why don't you get a
sandwich
like it would it would it would why did
you make yourself
like the biggest sandwich you can make
and i'd be like oh
great idea like i just started to have
these small
good ideas that were not like anything
i'd ever heard when i was afraid before
yeah then i had all these crazy
spiritual experiences and
like one of the things i had this great
sponsor joan the bone
god i loved her she was so great
she was the kind of girl who lived in
alaska and would
go to the bar when it was like 50 below
in a tutu
i mean you know she was just like a
badass like she was just and she was a
harvard social theorist too i've got to
tell you she would just
all that and a bowl of biscuits yeah
sounds like a a mobster what is
the what's the what's the origin of the
name do you have any idea i just called
her that that was my nickname for joan
the bone i see i see right
joan the bone and joan would tell me
things like
i was such an ingrate she'd say you have
to make a gratitude list
and so she called me and said what's on
your gratitude list i would say
i have all my limbs she'd say no okay
here's what you're going to do
you're going to make a gratitude list
every day this month for every letter of
the alphabet and you're gonna call me
and read it to me
i said shut the [ __ ] up i'm not gonna do
that she's like yes you are or else you
know like i won't talk to you anymore
i'd be like okay
so i just started crying i just started
try instead of sitting there with my
arms crossed and my lower lip stuck out
and my baseball cap pulled down over my
eyes
i just started trying [ __ ] that people
who were happier than me suggested i
should try
it was so simple and i started to get a
sense
um and so one of the things i said to
her she said you've got to pray for what
you want what are you praying for he
said i pray to stand it
yeah not to kill myself not to
stand it to stand it just to get through
the [ __ ] day that's what i'm praying
for
and she said okay well you gotta pray
for what you want what do you want i
said
i made nine thousand dollars this year i
would like some money
please she said well why don't you pray
for money i'm like you can't pray for
that she's like well
why not i said okay so i would literally
get on my knees in the morning say
keep me sober i would like some money
i'm not even making this up and i would
get on my knees and say thank you for
keeping me sober i would still like some
money
three weeks later after i started it's a
true story and you can look it up
i get a phone call from a guy who says
he's from this foundation he's giving me
thirty five thousand dollars that i'd
never applied for or asked for that
somebody just put me up for
and i so thought it was i thought it was
my friend george
playing a trick on me and says you know
[ __ ] you george and i hang the phone up
and the guy calls back and he asked me
on you know the speakerphone you can
hear people laughing
maniacally so i've never gotten money
from prayer
again but but and then joan the vote
says well you must believe that there's
some sort of god i was like no because
they
they were meeting to give me that prize
before
i had stopped drinking and started
praying and she said jesus
christ and i would also talk to her all
the time so i'd say how can there be a
god because look at the holocaust how do
she's like god didn't do the holocaust
people did the holocaust like what are
you mad at god for
people did that god didn't do that has
nothing to do with god
so that's how my prayer life started
it's bizarre story
i like bizarre so ignatian exercises
does that mean anything to you yes
yes i became a catholic i became a
catholic and i
do something i practice a kind of
spirituality called ignatian
spirituality which
when you become a jesuit you go away to
the jesuit place
on the jesuit making place you do a
quote
you you go to jesuit school and then
they put give you this
30 day these 30 day exercises and the
purpose of the exercises
is to find god in all things
so like this election
i just turned around to look at my
screen to see if we had a new president
so this election for instance just a
side note somebody just sent me a text
before we started recording and said the
entire country has
electile dysfunction which i thought was
pretty clever
why didn't i think of that oh that was
i thought that was great yeah it was a
clever turn of phrase yes
oh my god no it really is so finding god
in all things
i need god in all things so that means
you know like when the car breaks down
instead of thinking
you know your cruel fate you know has
come to hurt you you so what you do
actually tim is
is in the morning i do a prayer and
meditation
thing for 20 minutes where i do like
centering prayer
for maybe i don't know five six seven
minutes and then i read a scripture and
i meditate on the scripture and
and then i have a bunch of people i pray
for i have a list of people i pray for
and things i pray for
then at night i do something called the
examine of conscience
where you it's not like going over your
day making a list of
good things that happened or whatever
and then repenting for the bad things it
sounds like that but it's not that what
it is
is you kind of press play on the
recorder of your day
so you think i woke up and said what did
i do where was i
what mindset was i in and you close your
eyes and you try to
review your day literally like you're
watching a movie
and moments where you see moments of
grace
or or luck or even something you know a
good sandwich something yummy to eat
or you're supposed to savor
those moments and occupy those moments
and it's a very
it's a very body-oriented exercise
you're supposed to
smell what do you smell what do you hear
what do you taste
how do your clothes feel you're supposed
to really
recreate that moment in a sensory way
and thank god for
the grace or the gift of that and then
you you kind of press play again
and you see moments where you turned
away from god or you
you didn't your best self didn't act and
you
uh say yeah i want to do better next
time you know
instead of snapping at the robo
call voice snapping at siri because she
doesn't understand me
and love me for myself alone you know to
just
uh you know i wish i were i'd you know
tomorrow i'd like to be more patient
help me to be more patient so
what it does is it made those moments of
gratitude
and i also keep kind of a list or
journal of those things and
a prayer journal a daily i don't keep a
journal journal but i keep a daily
prayer journal in
and i just will kind of highlight
some of those things like for me today
right now steve kranacki's haircut which
i know he does
himself i don't know the guy who
delivers the
big map thing on msnbc i just like the
guy
i just like him every time i see him i
feel like
i'm spending the night at my
girlfriend's house and and he's her
nerdy brother
who's like secretly hot i had this flash
of panic so i was like oh
[ __ ] you're somebody important i'm not
saying it's unimportant but i'm just
saying oh god there's another name that
i
have to pretend i know the guy who
delivers
the the darn you know what the electoral
map says on msnbc
so if you're a liberal you're like a nut
and you watch this way other people
watch other things
so he's this really nerdy kind of math
goop
guy who wears like khakis
and a really like a clip-on tie
and has this really bad haircut and i
just have a complete crush on him
i just crush on him i don't even like
young men i don't i really don't
you have to have some you know you have
to have a
some hair coming out of yours for me to
want to date you but this guy just does
it for me
i just like him i'm just like so wait a
second
tie that together for you is that does
that mean anything to do with the prayer
journal
yes or were you just confessing that oh
no no it's it's i have a crush on a ton
of this guy who's on tv every night and
it tickles me to see him as kind of a
little thrill
it's a little thrill to see him it
really is it's so stupid
but it's also it makes me feel like a
child it makes me feel like it like i'm
in junior high school
and so there's something innocent and
sweet about it
also the fact that he's so dorky i like
i just like that
so you have a prayer journal you have
the commonplace
journal right you have any other
journals no that's
it the prayer journal i don't really
i only write like actually right and i
it's mostly kind of looks like a list
do you know what i'm saying it's mostly
like a list of things like the lady
uh the lady at my drug store
who the my pharmacist who uh they were
all out
of you know the pneumonia vaccine i get
pneumonia a lot
and she went out of her way to call me
and say you know i got you the pneumonia
if you can come in right now that we had
a cancellation i
you know i can do that just kindnesses
moments of kindness but also moments
of presence and awareness of god
a lot of people feel it in nature i feel
a little bit in central park which is
all the nature i have
you're out i am currently in austin
texas which is home base for me
shut the front door yeah i've been here
for three years
i live in the republic of boston
republic of texas one of my favorite
t-shirts
not everyone's going to get this but is
a shirt with the texas flag which says
most likely to secede
[Laughter]
which i quite like yes so i'm in texas
how did you wind up down there i would
argue that i'm not in texas
but courtney i know right listen or do
you have a weapon
if you have a weapon you belong i do god
don't get good for you what do you have
can i ask can we talk west as far as
weapons yeah sure i
i have a a seven millimeter uh windmag
hunting rifle i have a glock
34 which is nine millimeter i know what
it did i know what a nine millimeter
i don't know what a nine millimeter i'm
not explaining it for you i'm explaining
it just like getting on your knees not
for
not for god it's for you i'm explaining
to the listeners so
nine millimeter glock 34 i have an m
p 45 and
a few other do you hunt firearms that i
don't use much
i hunt but infrequently and that started
in 2012. i always had a very negative
association with hunting uh
yeah yeah i had a very negative
association because i saw very
irresponsible
of course hunting on long island yep
and then in the process of working on
the four-hour chef
and learning to forage i felt
it was incumbent upon me to hunt
and if i were to consume animal protein
so i had
my first deer hunt with an incredible
hunter and
conservationist named steve ronella and
that really completely shifted my lens
on how ethical and responsible hunting
could be now
in texas you have the whole spectrum
from responsible
you know machine gunning hogs from
helicopters which i do not partake in
although people could argue it's an
invasive species etc etc but yes
so i do hunt infrequently probably
you know let's just call it once every
year or two you know those javelina hogs
are fun to shoot i'm sorry to say it
i'm embarrassed to say it but i've shot
a javelina hog
so um i'm anti-gun but pro hunting
so does that make sense it does i mean
i'm just imagining
these kind of backwood kiwis
in new zealand hunting hogs with knives
walking into the woods barefoot which is
a real thing i know a case
one guy who did that so you can be pro
hunting while being anti-anti-gun i
think that's
possible no but i mean i if i were to
hunt i would hunt with a gun but i'm
it's funny one of my best friends is a
young writer named philla marsh who's in
a mate he's one of those guys who stocks
his freezer with
bow and arrow kill venison he called me
this week and said a very interesting
just kill this
a deer and he said you know the longer i
hunt
you know the only thing i hate about it
is the killing
i think there's there's a lot of shared
sentiment
to that but yeah a lot of hunters
yeah i mean the most reverent people i
know about the natural world
are are practicing many of them are
practicing hunters
true fact well i want to use this to
tie a bunch of things together in the
most awkward fashion possible
that's okay because i've been trying to
force fit a segway somewhere so i might
as well do it here
and and that is
to hear your description or explanation
of
how some of your wordsmithing came to be
part of what i enjoy
so much about your writing is that
you have this let me get this right time
critic lev grossman
said in his review of lit carr seems to
have been born with the inability to
write a dishonest or boring sentence
that's high praise now love
the least the least boring sentences for
me
and god i wish i could remember it but
you take this
what seems like this sensitivity to
language
and poetry to create sentences
using cat [ __ ] sandwich metaphors right
and so on which also seems to me and
maybe this is
you tell me if this is warranted or not
but to be a very kind of texan
thing also it kind of makes me think of
like a trial
lawyer in god knows where in texas
right who gets up and just demolishes
some slick
trial attorney from los angeles in a
complete
mismatch right i mean just dismantle
someone with these
really clever turns of phrase
where does that come from or how did
that develop in you because i do think
it is one of your one of your
superpowers
well i think growing up in texas is it's
a storytelling culture you know i
texas idiom is poetry as far as i'm
concerned and i had two great
practitioners
i'm a seventh generation texan uh on my
mother's side and fifth generation and
my daddy so
my daddy was a great bar room
storyteller i mean he was
he was a labor union organizer for the
oil chemical and atomic workers local 12
1242 and um he was
just funny as a crutch and told these
amazing kind of
tall tales like out of out of mark twain
and but he
also spoke in poetry like he would say
like a woman with an ample behind he'd
say uh she has a butt like two bulldogs
fighting in a bag
and for him that was a compliment there
was nothing
insulting about that that he he used to
call me i'm a little
skinny thing he used to call me a gimlet
ass pokey you need
you need some tower on that ass you need
you need you got you a gimlet ass i
don't even know what that is but
i knew it wasn't good a little flat butt
or he would say
it's raining like a cow pissing on a
flat rock
you can scan that by the way it's
raining like a cow
pissing on flat rock
it's it's wait what do you mean by scan
real quick
i mean like like shakespeare is iambic
pentameter or my first love poem that
was ever written to me i saw you on your
horse today your eyes like eggs your
hair like hey that's like but it's
iambic pentameter
so that that's uh it doesn't matter what
it is but you can hear it when i say it
right
that it's raining like a cow
pissing on a flat rock and that you hit
that flat rock
it creates for one thing it creates a
whole
landscape in which cows piss on flat
rocks
and people stand around and marble and
go my goodness
looky at that and then you attribute
that to the rain
it's it's a metaphor it operates way
beyond the bounds
of propriety it's not how you talk in
church you're not supposed to talk like
this
so the minute you say this and somebody
laughs at it
you have them they're in your boat they
have transgressed
but by laughing at your joke well daddy
was just the master of a story
but he was also a poetic imagery i mean
to me
all that poetry i grew up i was steeped
in it my mother
who was an enormous reader who read you
know
everything chinese history and and
russian novels and
philosophy and and just read
everything was just the master of
you know i remember when she was dying
somebody she had all these old men she
were always trying to marry her which
why but she's dying she's actively dying
and one of these
old boyfriends has come to see her at
the hospital in houston and
the nurse been suffering says miss carr
your husband's here to see you and she
says well he must look like [ __ ] he's
been dead 20 years
and you know i mean she just she just
she just can't stop herself from saying
like the most horrible thing you've ever
thought
and so i think between the two of them
and just growing up
in in texas the idiom the language i
grew up with
is epically beautiful
and the need to not be boring when you
speak
you know people will i'm gonna stomp a
mud hole in your ass
that is so much better than i'm gonna
whip your ass
it's just like i yeah right or my friend
dooney got in a fight once with a guy in
a bar
and the guy said and he told the
greatest story about it
it was actually the guy he decided to
stab he went out in his truck and got a
knife and came back with like a swiss
army knife
and he started facing this guy who was a
state congressman by the way i won't
tell you his name
but he starts chasing him around this
bar well to brandish a weapon
in a place where alcohol is served is a
mandatory i think ten year sentence
seven
ten some big you know it's not it's
frowned upon
and he's chasing this guy around and
what somebody says to danny at one point
that's a little bitty old knife you got
through he said well notice he don't
want to get stabbed by it
and then then he runs out and then we
hear the siren so here comes the say
here comes all
woo then he runs out he gets in his
truck
and one of those mall cops security guys
runs out and dude he says he stands in
front of my truck in front of my
headlights
he's got a belt buckle that will pick up
hbo
and he he holds his hands up and goes
halt
halt and dooney just puts it in first
gear and hits the guy
i mean he doesn't hit him hard but he
knocks him down
and then leaves and gets pulled over and
is convinced he's going to prison
for brandishing this weapon for trying
to hit this guy but anyway it turns out
he had to call the guy to apologize the
guy's daddy knew dooney's daddy
and he said all he wants you to do is
apologize and do this like apologize
you know i'll blow the guy like are you
kidding
i don't want to go to jail of course
i'll apologize so but he but
here's the punchline of the story and
this is what makes dooney still my best
friend since i was 15.
so he calls the guy out and the guy
answers but he goes
uh and dude he goes i am so sorry man
about last night i am so sorry the guy
says you
almost killed me
and uh dooney says man i'm so sorry i
didn't know it was you
don't you want to say that though the
next time somebody happened i didn't
know it was you the next time you do
some horrible things
next time i get in a really stupid
argument with my girlfriend that's what
i'm going to use don't you want to say i
didn't know it was you
honey i don't know only in the state of
texas do you have that story
it's just got all the elements of a
texted story
how could i not love it down there i
mean oh my god
let's talk about revision okay revision
i'm a big advisor i'm a big
so you have said you know anyone who's
read a rough draft of anything i write
is just shocked at how bad it is
it's terrible and what does the process
look like i mean
i know this is a very hopefully doesn't
sound like a really naive question
because i know that there's a there are
many many aspects to revision
so i'll i'll lead with just a bit this
is from writermag.com but carl says she
takes a hard look at every sentence she
writes can i make the sentence less
boring more interesting prettier more
colorful
more true so that's a teaser what does
your revision process look like because
i've read that you threw out something
like 1200 pages
about 1200 pages of lit yeah finished
pages
too that's not draft and that was
written over about
i want to say five or six years and i
remember when i threw it out
tim i was so upset i had been well first
off
they were about they were about to hang
me i was so late i was like seven years
late
on a contract i mean they and so i
finally my agent called me and said
you know you're gonna you're gonna have
to i said you know what i will sell
my apartment and give the damn money
back
if they don't shut up and leave me alone
like it's just going to take me a minute
so anyway so i had sent them
i don't know i'd sent them like 130 140
pages and my editor at the time
estimated that i'd thrown out 1200 pages
and
let me tell you when she said that they
sucked as bad as i thought they sucked
i mean i knew they sucked when they said
how much i didn't want to send them i
wanted to keep working on them so
i just i went to bed for like
two days and i watched you know dr
phil reruns and a lot of cooking shows
and i ordered a lot of curry i think i
had a whole pizza at one point
and slopped around in my bathrobe
and then i called donda lil i was one of
the people i call
uh it's like you know the nuclear button
you know who's like
just one of the great novelists and
who's also happens to be a friend of
mine and i said don
i think i'm writing him he's like what
are you crying about i said i think i'm
writing a bad
book and he said well who doesn't
and i thought about that and i thought
god he's right tall story's written bad
but i mean people i read
you know every writer i know has written
a bad book so
okay so okay so maybe it's just supposed
gonna be a bad book
but it's the book that's standing in
line to be written
and i think i got i became willing to
fail to just
say what happened so basically what it
looks like
is just clawing through a line at a time
or a sentence at a time
i think one example i give in the art of
memoir is that when i'm
my mother is driving me to college and i
think
the sentence i started with was
something like
mother drove me to college in her yellow
station wagon
we stopped every night at the holiday
inn and got
drunk on screwdrivers i can't remember
might have said puke and drunk on
screwdrivers
i somehow was able to remember being
in that car the thing about my mother's
yellow station wagon
was that it didn't have an air
conditioner so
at that time you could buy an air
conditioner that's strapped under
the dashboard well it would build up
condensation and when she turned
right and i was sitting in the you know
shotgun
the water in the air conditioner would
spill out onto my bare feet
and it was icy icy cold water
and i remembered that we had stopped and
gotten a bushel of peaches
in arkansas and she was drinking vodka
dried and drinking vodka
and and orange juice and eating these
watching or eat a peach you know when
you're 17 years old to watch your mother
eat
and show any desire for anything is just
so horrifying
you just want to die there's just
nothing uglier than watching your mother
eat a peach
when you're 17. you just think my god
woman
shut your mouth take a smaller bite
jesus it's not going anywhere
you know but i the smell of the peaches
and being in and suddenly i remembered
that i had a copy of a hundred years of
solitude
that i had got that was her book that i
had started reading
she said read it aloud to me and i
remembered
reading that book and driving and i
remembered
the you know you grew up around these
kind of texas dirk farms i mean there's
plenty of
corporate farming in the state of texas
but then you get to the midwest
and it's just so organized it's just
there aren't the rusted cars in the yard
in the refrigerator on the porch you
know it's
these rows and rows of corn and these
big
cinnamon colored silos and i remember
driving into that landscape up to that
college
and reading that book and thinking i
could be a writer i could
i i somehow was able to remember those
details and
occupy that body in space and time and
remember how disgusted i was
by my mother and how terrified i was
that i wouldn't do well
at school that i would fail i've been
such a screw-up you know i've been
arrested the year before
with a bunch of kids and there was a
bunch of dope and some of them went to
jail and i didn't
because the judge
was a guy who had known my mother when
she was a
a reporter for the local newspaper and i
still remember
sitting and hit she came to pick me up
wearing a leopard
she had leopard skin pajamas it was july
4th
and she had on a beaver coat with a mink
collar
and those leopard skin pajamas in the on
this hot
night in coons county texas and here
sits his judge behind us this
liver-spotted judge
with these palsied hands and every meal
he's ever eaten on his tie
when she came to pick me up and he said
i remember your
mother she was the most beautiful woman
i'd ever seen and she said oh
you old fool i mean it was just
like oh my god mother get me out of here
sucking up is underrated so anyway yeah
i think
it's it's memory it's i do an exercise
with
my um i just did it the other day for a
colleague of mine dana spietta a
wonderful young
novelist i teach with and she's teaching
an undergraduate class and i said you
know i want to do this right there are
90 kids in the class
she said i said i want to do this
writing exercise she well they're
writing you know it's been uneven and i
said
trust me everyone will write well
and you have them focus on a room they
grew up in
and to try to occupy the smell to
try to remember a room you were in where
your mother's cooking your grandmother
river you
had a good meal when you were little
and try to close your eyes and smell
that
because you know smell is the most
primordial
memory and the most emotional memory and
it's stored way back in that
snake brain hypothalamus we have that is
where all the trouble starts
you try to get in that memory and
interrogate your body about what you can
smell
taste touch and then finally what you
want
what are you yearning for and what's
keeping you from getting it
maybe it's a bite of the brisket or some
of the barbecue or daddy's oysters
coming up
out of the fryer or what's going to keep
you from getting it it's my big footed
sister who is daddy said nothing ever
got between her and a
bag of groceries you know she's gonna
get all the oysters and i won't get any
and so it's really more about trying to
occupy
a former self because i think as you
know just as in trauma
the body remembers the body also
remembers beauty
it also remembers pleasure and love and
uh those other things too
so so the body
keeps the score and if you go
excavating for these memories sometimes
there are costs associated with that
yeah i've you know i've read that while
you were working on
the liars club that you'd suddenly fall
asleep in the middle of the afternoon as
if you'd
driven all night and you would sob you'd
really suffer
what did you do to cope with that pain
and i should just say
you and i were chatting before the
recording about
trauma a bit and you know i've recently
described some of my childhood sexual
abuse and
the podcast that i did related to it
didn't seem to
exact a horrifying toll
but the process years before of trying
to write about it and getting a
very very rough draft brutalized me
and just left me
paralytic for god more than six months
in some ways
and i just yeah thank you for
saying that and i i'm horrified by the
experience and also
fascinated by it in a way because i i
don't know why those two things should
be so different
and i'd just love to hear you expand a
bit
on the price that you've
paid or your experience with dredging up
a lot of these memories or recalling
them
putting them down and why writing
seems at least in my experience to be so
different from some other forms of
expressing these things
well i mean because you're alone uh
you're alone
i mean that's i mean that's for me where
the prayer and the god
and the god comes in i do have a sense
now that i didn't have
back in the day i mean when i was by the
time i started writing liars club
how old was i i don't know 35
i've been in therapy for 16 years
and i'd also had a prayer practice for
um you know a meditation and prayer
practice for some years i
i hadn't converted i wasn't a christian
i didn't i was a catholic
but i was about to become catholic and i
was
very active in recovery programs
and i had a sponsor and i also had
based on all of those efforts
i had done a lot of the processing and
recovery
i had flown down to texas when i was 23
years old and
got my mother drunk on margaritas and
told her you know you tried to kill me
with a butcher knife and it's not
because i was a bad
kid and it ruined my life and what the
hell was wrong with you what was going
on
you know i had done a lot of that work
before i and i tell people when they
tell me they want to write a memoir
about some horrible stretch of
childhood or some awful period of trauma
maybe they don't maybe they don't right
now
so i think i had a sense of
you know when i was drinking my idea of
medicating myself or anesthetizing
myself that was all i knew how to do
that was what my parents told me to do
that was all they knew how to do
was try to drink it away uh you know my
daddy was in the battle of the bulge i
mean he went and went in at normandy and
he came out at buchamall
i mean that's plenty of trauma plus
being married to my mother would have
been simple
uh there's only one person with a weapon
as opposed to the nazis so
yeah i think i'm a big
fan of a hot bath
i'm a big fan of nutritious food i'm a
big fan
of cardio even now i mean i'm 65 i don't
do
five dance classes a week but i get up
in the morning and i
you know walk four miles and then i do
pilates
three or four times a week and i take a
dance class a couple times a week and
all those things keep me in my body and
when i'm in a lot of pain i take care of
myself when i've
when i was drinking i felt like i had
this screaming baby that i was holding
and i was screaming at it
all the time to shut up so yeah i think
i still have even
writing anything now i find very i'm not
dealing with anything like that i'm so
much but i'm also
i'm so much happier now than i've ever
been in my life
i mean i'm 65 years old i've never been
so happy in my life
i've never been less good looking
had less social power had you know
any of the things that you would think
would make me happy joyous and free and
i'm just
i wake up every day really
feeling lucky to be alive and feeling
loved and feeling like
not every day i mean i wake up plenty of
days and i'm
you know mad as an old stump piss ant
but
most of my days are pretty lit up
and it's a lifetime of practice so i
just
you know i tell a lot of my students my
young students you know want to write
about
sexual assault or or trauma
of various kinds well maybe you know
why don't you get some treatment for
this first why don't you treat your
heart first treat your body treat
yourself
with a lot of care and see if this is
what you want to write about
right now something you can write about
maybe five years from now or something
you know
what advice would you give yourself
about
therapy if you were talking to your 19
or 20 year old self
and how were you first convinced
to go to therapy i remember you
mentioning that long ago you know i
didn't have to be convinced i mean
here's the other thing
yeah no and there weren't a lot of
people saying gee i wish you'd stop
drinking
i mean i led a pretty isolated existence
the way a lot of people who grew up the
way i
grew up do i mean my idea of telling
somebody how i felt i remember
right before i stopped drinking i
remember i was teaching well
i sort of all over the academic ghetto
around boston but i remember
specifically one day at tufts i was
copying something for a class and i was
i was had dropped my kid off like
vomiting out the side of the car
before i dropped him off at daycare i
mean
and then i drove to tufts and i was
xeroxing something and somebody said how
you doing mary and i was like
you know i want to blow my [ __ ]
brains out and that was my idea of
telling somebody how i felt
you know making a glib sort of awkward
socially awkward statement to somebody i
hardly knew
and i've been in therapy then for a
while but i was also drinking
every day everything i could get my
mitts on so
i don't know what is good what is good
therapy to you because
therapy is is a term that's extremely
broad it's kind of like saying medicine
right yeah exactly there's so many
different specialties
what has proven to be good therapy for
you you know i think it
totally depends on the on the person i
mean the best
the best therapist i ever had i think
i mean for me the difference in therapy
and recovery i think
in therapy i'm i'm the baby and they're
the mommy
and that model sort of uh when i
especially when i first started i just
felt like i needed a lot of nurturing
and i had great therapists you know my
first therapist when i look back on
things he said and did was
insane he would have been fired he told
me to go down after he'd been seeing me
nine months
and confront my homicidal suicidal
mother about all this horrible stuff
she'd done to me
and i did it and he said i won't see you
until you do it
wow i mean
nobody's ever done any in for a pound
yeah i know i mean i look back on it i
was like he was crazy
nobody's ever i had a great therapist
when my son was a baby who was a
psychologist phd psychologist
and who really helped me
try to learn how to be a mother when i
hadn't had one
and all the you know feelings that come
up around
what you didn't get when you were a
child when you have a child
the protection and stuff it's funny my
son
watches me with his daughter now and
just says i don't know
you know sort of gives me nothing but
a stroke and i said let me just tell you
i was not this good with you
like i was crazy about you and i loved
you but i didn't have what i have now
that i have with her that's just it's
not even
i don't even break a sweat going in
there i can do this stuff that i was
funny i was in
prospect i babysit one or two days a
week i was in prospect park this week
and i had taken her across the park in a
stroller
and a thunderstorm broke out i mean
pouring rain
and she is the i've never shared dna
with somebody this good-natured
as this baby this baby cou smiles
laughs never cries i mean sleeps eats
is just the best natured kid i i used to
babysit
in high school in college so i've taken
care of a lot of babies and she's just
the easiest kid
i get across the thing is pouring rain
and
i've got and she starts screaming crying
like she's being beaten
and i take her out of the stroller and i
hold her and she calms down i go to put
her back in the stroller she just starts
screaming
crying again well it's two miles across
a muddy field in the pouring rain and
i've got a stroller and a bunch of crap
and i've got this
you know 27 pound unit
screaming unit and uh i just had no
problem doing it
and when i was 40 years old 35 years old
it would have been like being beaten
with a hose
and i just i just thought you know what
daddy was in the battle of the bulge
this is not that hard you know i just
had the physical energy
even at my age that i didn't know i had
to do it and i got back to the house and
i went to fold up the stroller there was
four inches of freezing water in the
bottom of the stroller that i've been
putting her in
and she was soaked through to her skin
yeah there was like she was perfectly
reasonable to be
you know now i understand i could have
just emptied it out and put her in the
stroller and
wrapped her up in a blanket but i didn't
know what it was but i just thought well
i'll get her home and it'll be fine you
know i didn't feel like oh my god oh my
god i'm a terrible mother and i'm gonna
wind up
trying to stab her with a butcher knife
which is how i felt when my kid was that
age
you know i didn't know that i wasn't
going to be my mother i wasn't
i didn't know that so scary
that is scary yeah super scary
and you know it sounds like please
correct me if i'm wrong but that you've
learned in some form or fashion or maybe
many forms and fashions to wear the
world
like a loose garment i'd love to know if
you agree or disagree because
based on my reading
well okay so your first confession
absolutely not no
priest said to you where the world like
a loose garment what does that mean
to you well i mean i think it's not you
know the problem isn't whatever your
mind is telling you the problem is the
problem is the fear
and for me the solution to fear is
curiosity
and presence and
i can't be terrified and curious
at the same time and so when i
was walking the baby across the
fields just all i was was physically
uncomfortable i mean i was
you know i was thinking gee can i shove
this thing and hold her
you know and get everything and get all
this stuff
how am i going to do you know and so i
went crossways across the mud field so
i'm shoving the stroller and carrying
her
i didn't know physically if i could do
it i was
sort of dubious i was thought maybe i
can't do this but all i had to do was do
it i thought well if i get tired i'll
sit down it'll rain on me a minute and
i'll get up and go again
like that's what we'll do but i don't
know i
i wouldn't say it's not my nature to be
here's the way i put it i tell people
it's like i have a trick knee
it's like most of the time i walk fine i
run fine
i can you know squat uh more than my
body weight
and do advanced pilates for an hour and
10 minutes
and i'm tough as a boot but there are
days
that when there are days that i don't
feel that way or there are moments where
i get
my knee goes out and i fall on the
ground and i
all i have to do is honor those moments
all i have to do is i have a i have a
heating pad i have a weighted blanket
you know
my kids have a pitbull i'll bring to
stay with me while
an idiot is a my little comfort animal
you know i call people i still have a
sponsor i still have a therapist
i don't talk to all the time but i
didn't have to be convinced to go into
therapy i knew i needed it but when i
first started
it as you know it was just so damn
painful
and i just for those of your listeners
out there if you're having a hard time i
just want to say it's like you lance a
boil
and the infection is draining off and if
you can just
get by that it's going to tell you that
it's endless but it's
not endless there's a bottom to it
so did you ever smoke you never did i
was never a smoker
no yeah you're just such a jock you're
such a specimen
you're such a fascinating tim well well
we're all specimens it depends on how we
look on the autopsy table
but the the uh i was born premature so i
have respiratory issues on my left lung
and that does also that that was part of
it
so i had a lot of breathing issues
growing up to begin with
and secondly i was sports saved me
so sports kept me out of a lot of
trouble yeah
i you know i was good at sports and then
i quit when i was like
i quit and uh i'm much more of a jock
now than i was then
you know i wanted to ask about smoking
yeah i was gonna ask you about smoking
because when you quit smoking
there's a phenomenon that happens that's
it's also when you quit drinking but
somehow it's more intense when you smoke
you'll have a craving for a cigarette
and the
craving is as intense
as it was the first day you quit it's as
overpowering but if you just keep note
of how
long the craving lasts and how many of
them there are
they're as intense but they're not
as long and as frequent
so it's the same thing about suffering
when you first start therapy or you
first lance that boil and you're
unearthing some of the painful things
you grew up with
it's as intense the first day and you
just feel like oh my god i'm in the burn
ward and i just got snatched out of the
fire and
every ounce of me hurts and i want to
run screaming down the street like my
air's on fire
and it just won't last as long as it did
the first time
and so for your listeners if that you
know if you're just
you know looking at hard things that you
grew up with or you're
trying to quit smoking trying to quit
drinking trying to recover from
trauma i promise you
i will send you money if this is not
true
that it will get easier it's just it's
not linear and there will be those days
when it's as
painful as the first annual thing but
i'm no better than i was but you
are you just it doesn't feel that way
yeah excellent uh advice just just
a few more questions i'm having so much
fun i could go forever but
i you know dude
ah do i do i though i don't know i mean
where in austin do you live
well i i spend most of my time downtown
for recording
and then uh live in the burbs outside of
that
i love it i love it in austin and
expect to be here for quite some time i
wanted to move here right after college
i didn't get the job and uh there was
those morons
they screwed up yeah well you know
possibly
i also think that that could have been
in everyone's best interest
really i i think i make it quite
terrible employee in most circumstances
me too but at the time at the time
and uh you know i didn't expect this to
lead here but at the time
that i was not given the
the green light to get an offer from
trilogy software way back in the day it
seemed like a death blow right this
seemed
like the end of the world because i put
a lot of eggs in that basket i didn't
want to do
anything that was recruiting on campus
really otherwise
and i listened to you and watched your
syracuse university commencement
speech yeah that's so nice of you
there's there's uh and then i read
i read a transcript and i think this is
from the speech unless it was
sort of mistranscribed but here's the
paragraph almost every time i was super
afraid it was of the wrong
thing and stuff that first looked like
the worst most humiliating thing
that could ever happen almost always led
me to something extraordinary and very
fine
so my question is could you give us an
example of that that comes to mind
it could be something humiliating it
could be a favorite failure but anything
that i'll tell you as it turns out one
of the pr when i first did uh when i
first did a kind of moral inventory and
recovery that they encouraged you to do
i had a lot of resentments against god
like
when you say they this is in a 12-step
program yeah
and uh john labone you know
joan the bonfire like one of the things
i really resented god for
my son who was just this little
beautiful blonde blond-haired blue-eyed
and a
tank of a boy a natural kind of athlete
when he was little he was sick
all the time i mean he would get a cold
and he would get these sinus infections
his fever would go to like 105
we'd rush him to children's hospital in
boston
it was terrifying we're always rushing
to emergency rooms because his fever was
so bleeding
high and just so terrifying
and so i never slept
i never slept and i was depressed i was
probably postpartumly depressed and and
i was drinking
i by then i'd started to decide drinking
would help me take care of a sick child
great idea mir is like the bad mom in
the after school special
and um and
so what and i remember
so when it came time to do ignatian
spiritual exercises you're trying to
find god in all things where is god in
that
where is god in a sick baby
i'll tell you secret when i actually
looked at my
life and the decisions i was making
i would have kept drinking if i'd had
one of those playboy babies
you know that like sleeps 12 hours a
night
and you know never is sick and just you
know
coos and cuddles and like and and i had
been able to
i would have kept drinking if i'd had my
granddaughter
who's like the easiest like 12 hour
night sleeper eats everything you give
her laughs at everything you did
i would have kept drinking i could not
physically
drink the way a real alcoholic needs to
drink
and take care of a kid who was sick all
the time couldn't do it
and work and make a living i couldn't do
all those things it's too hard
and so i don't think god sent pathogens
into my
infant son's body i don't know how any
of this works
but when i ask where god is in this that
physical
my own physical discomfort
forced me to get sober
so my sister died this summer very
suddenly a pancreatic cancer in less
than a week
sorry yeah i'm sorry too you know
we were not in touch we had a
terrible childhood and we had not been
really in touch for uh seven years
and that was my choice
and i remember saying to my therapist
isn't it going to be terrible when she
dies she said yeah it's going to be
terrible anyway
and although it's horrible that she's
dead there's nothing i
feel my love for her i don't have to
defend myself
against my love for her the way i did
when we were estranged i can cherish
and remember all the times we were there
for each other
all the ages
we were in each other's lives
and yeah it's i would give anything for
her to be alive but i still think our
not being in touch was the best thing
for both of us
you know i don't regret that
and there's this amazing gift to me of
being in touch now with her son
and her husband and her stepchildren and
i would give anything if she were alive
but there are gifts
in this suffering that are real
spiritual gifts i practice
when things happen that i find very
disappointing my son had a film coming
out his first feature film coming out
at tribeca film festival and
it's a global pandemic and so there is
no tribeca film festival and he's raised
somehow all this money and put
years worth of work in and got you know
and moved heaven and earth and you know
what the film's being released he's got
a great distribution deal
he just won best director at frightfest
and you know it's unfolding just the way
it needs to unfold
it's getting curious about about where
the light is you know just being curious
about where the light is
getting curious about where the light is
and the all powerful
reframe and it is really incredible
what can happen as you said when you
really get curious i have to say this
i fear on air tim because i have to say
it i just
i have so many young people who come to
me about sexual assault so many young
men
who've come to me my students young
writers young poets
and you're being open about this on this
podcast
has just been such a gift
to all these young men thank you
so good for you so good for you so a
horrible thing
that happened to you that's being used
to help a lot of give a lot of people
hope and it's going to prompt a lot of
healing
i i hope so and i i've seen
[Music]
i've seen a lot come out of the woodwork
and
it's been simultaneously and i know
you've experienced this certainly
it's been simultaneously appalling
rewarding and
brutal in a way i mean it's it's all of
those things i mean there's a lot of
pain
and beauty in it and you know i'll just
mention that of my closest male friends
and there really aren't that many i
don't collect
friends like uh you know little
porcelain teacups or whatever people
collect
i have a fairly small ish circle and i
would say
30 of my closest male friends
reached out to me after that podcast to
describe their own
experiences with sexual abuse that i
know nothing about and these are people
i've known for
a very long time so i hope there's
healing
of course there is i hope so we're
living look we're living look we're not
curled up on the backwards of mental
institutions and we both could be
yeah very true very true
well mary we're going to talk again and
i want to tell you this
one more question which sometimes is a
dead end
and i'll i'll own that if it is okay
then but
we'll see where it goes the question is
if you could put anything on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to reach
billions of people
however many you want a word a phrase a
question a quote a poem
anything what might you put on that
that's so hardcore jesus
oh my god that is really god that's a
little
it's aggressive it's aggressive it's
hard it's aggressive it really is
it's a little javelina hogs as a pack of
javelin hogs running out of the bushes
at me
um what could i
uh what would i put and it doesn't have
to be the one and only this could just
be
the first billboard the first billboard
you know put down that gun you need a
sandwich
um
[Music]
you need a sandwich and a hot bath no i
know what i would put i would put 90
percent of what what's wrong with you
could be cured with a hot bath that's
what i'd put
i love it i love that well mary this has
been so much
fun i've really really
enjoyed this people can find you at your
website
marycard.com that's maryk arr.com
twitter
mary carr lit lit is there anything else
you'd like to
say suggest ask no just
let's all heal let's all heal as a
country no matter how different we think
we are
we're all suffering souls and we all
want to
want to heal this ribbon country of ours
so that's what i'm wishing for all of us
and wishing everybody a lot of love and
light today
and a big nice cigar
[Laughter]
[Music]
here here we're here get curious
look for the uh thank you mary all right
everybody take care you go do
you i will and to everybody listening
we'll link to everything that we've
mentioned
in the show notes at team dot blog
forward slash podcast and until next
time
thanks for listening hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get
a short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this podcast episode
is brought to you by
helix sleep sleep is super important to
me in the last few years
i've come to conclude it is the end-all
be-all that all good things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight lux mattress i also have one in
the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it
and now my dear listeners helix is
offering up to two hundred dollars off
of all mattress orders
and two free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim these are not cheap pillows either
so getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
ship
station the holiday season is fast
approaching and we know that people will
be buying more stuff
online than ever before all of these
trends to e-commerce have been
accelerated due to covet and much more
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of
record-breaking online shopping season
be ready with shipstation
shipstation.com is the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks you're managing
orders printing out discounted shipping
labels and getting your products out
fast happier holidays for you and your
customers
shipstation takes the hassle out of
holiday shipping no matter where you're
selling
on amazon etsy your website via shopify
or other platforms
shipstation brings all of your orders
into one simple
interface and shipstation works with all
of the major carriers usps
fedex ups even international you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution every time
and you can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved
for large fortune 500 companies it's no
wonder that shipstation is the number
one choice of online sellers and right
now
my listeners that's you guys can try
shipstation free
for 60 days when you use offer code tim
just go to the homepage shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage
and type in tim tim that's it go to
shipstation.com then enter offer code
tim shipstation.com
make ship happen
you